i think the tide is beginning to turn a
little bit i think people are getting a
little bit woke and they're getting a
little bit red pilled and they're
whatever term you want to use
specifically on fouchy
but what is turning the tide on fauchi
is a little
unfortunate to me
so you may have seen this story over the
weekend some some documents were
obtained
by the white coat waste project via a
freedom of information act request
that showed
that from october 2018 until february
2019
niaid that is the aspect of the national
institutes of health that dr fauci runs
and has run for decades spent 1.68
million dollars in taxpayer funds on
drug tests involving 44 beagle puppies
and the tests were pretty sick
a lot of them involved
well involved torturing the puppies i
guess that's that's how you'd put it you
know putting parts of the puppies bodies
in little sealed containers with hungry
little flies that would eat the puppies
alive or you know poisoning the puppies
and then you know dissecting them and
looking at what the effect of that on
their organs or in one report said they
ripped out the vocal cords of puppies so
they wouldn't need to hear the puppies
scream while they were conducting these
these medical experiments on them and
and in effect torturing them
this is all very sad this has people
outraged bipartisan calls now for fouchy
to resign or at least to be investigated
give an answer for this
i guess it's because i'm not a dog
person i don't know i'm not a dog person
i'm not a cat person i'm more a people
person
and i think it is an indictment of our
culture
that we are outraged
that dr fauci performed medical
experiments on beagles but we don't care
that our government experiments on
babies on fetal stem cells we create
vaccines out of the cells of killed
babies we kill almost a million babies a
year in this country through abortion
that's fine that's to be celebrated or
to be discussed in these very clinical
terms
but if you conduct a medical experiment
on a puppy that's a bridge too far
because because according to these
people the beagles
are much more precious
than the babies
that's that's what they think
it's frustrating because i don't have
any problem with medical experimentation
on
animals
i think it's actually a good thing
because you try out these
these
new treatments on animals and you see if
they work and if they don't work and
sometimes the treatments are going to
kill the animals and sometimes it's
going to improve the animals and then
this is a way of figuring out whether or
not it's going to work on people without
having to experiment on people whether
it's little babies or aborted fetal
cells or actual
adults you know fully grown adults in
the general population
right we don't
i would much rather experiment on a
beagle than on a human being at any
stage of development
whether we're talking about
a little baby
or a kid
or a teenager or an adult
i don't think animals have any rights i
don't think we should torture animals
but c.s lewis makes this point the
problem with animal cruelty is not that
animals have some rights that we are
violating when we
torture them it's that
torturing animals will dead in our
humanity the problem is actually still
for us so we shouldn't do it we should
be good stewards of creation
but there's nothing wrong with medical
experiments on
animals there is something wrong with
medical experiments on little babies
okay and on
adult humans and everyone in between i'm
so glad that you liked that clip i liked
it too i did i liked that you liked it
i'm glad that you're here and we're here
together i want to be together a lot
more okay
in order for that to happen you have to
ring that bell you have to subscribe you
have to head on over to apple podcast
spotify stitch or google play wherever
you get your podcasts you type in
michael knowles show
subscribe it'll just come directly into
your
podcast feed it's free
you will be up you will not get the
censored version you're going to get
the
totally politically incorrect
disallowed on most big tech platforms
point of view i'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]